le pilier tu ce bistrot tom
le pilier de bistrot en grec
et une espèce assez répandu surtout par
chez nous malgré les risques
connaissance immonde s'est rendu pour
vous au coeur même de leur refaire
messieurs s'il vous plaît
le
pilier tout ce que vous pouvez le
constater fait partie de la famille des
bipèdes pourtant certains soirs il lui
arrive de se déplacer à quatre pattes
dans la journée ils utilisent
généralement trois points d'appui la
jambe droite
la jambe gauche
et le comptoir
on reconnaît d'ailleurs les vieux
spécimens à une excroissance appelé du
rayon comptoir
le comportement des piliers tu cet
immeuble leurs règles de vie très
stricte s'appuie sur quelques grands
principes que nul ne peut transgresser
découvrons les ensembles peuvent attirer
et il faut le brûler et offre de cette
règle fondamentale est toujours suivie
d'une autre règle on que doit partir ce
serait du genre
oui la deuxième langue est ensuite
complété par une troisième au bassin
ouest
j'ai
je l'avais de s'octroyer
à partir de là apparaître une formule
qui sera utilisé un assemblement ont
broyé
ouais mais c'est le dernier le dernier
la drogue
selon les heures le pilier tu ce bistrot
hommes utilisent un langage différent
voici un exemple en début de journée
pour qui sont ces six aussi sont au sec
pour le chasseur qui sait chasse et son
chien
voici maintenant le même dialogue
enregistré quelques heures plus tard
bon
en dehors des grands principes qui
constituent une sorte de droit canon pas
le pilier tus utilise certaines
variantes d'origines diverses ainsi la
variante militaire
allauch au hazé scania et qu'il est
monté
cette formule martial entraîne
inévitablement une conséquence
battront mes pulsions même motif et
l'affilié tu sais très attentif à sa
santé galerie sujet à quelques maladies
spécifiques comme le palud comtois
ou encore la fièvre de bercy
maintenant mersey ne pas surtout
focus
et encore cela ne boivent pas tout ils
en vendent hertz
ou encore le blizzard elephant et se
rend aux us et au laser
des trompes qui couvre
t il jouer jouer
jouer trop enlevée
afin d'éviter ces inconvénients le
pilier tus n'hésite pas à donner
lui-même les instructions nécessaires
seront prévues au point mort ouais
benoît
sa culture médicale est d'ailleurs très
étendue en voici quelques exemples
on laissa du bois mais ça peut pas faire
de mal avec des plantes à
ou encore
aux os maison
mais ça peut pas faire de mal on en
donne du sens mana
ou encore
en roumanie
mais la bière et sadique à celle
généralement chaleureux et amical le
pilier du spis 30 hommes peut devenir
ference lorsque sa santé est en cause
regardez cette séquence et ben ouais
super
merci
[Applaudissements]
a pas de manipulation dans le whisky
non
merci messieurs pour bien apprécier
cette semaine revoyons la au ralenti
vous remarquerez tout d'abord que les
haricots des bérets sont encore bien
droit et calme que le regard est gentil
voir tendre que la luette est détendue
que le visage également mais bientôt
attention le sourire se fige pour le
devenir et à vulgaire rictus les yeux
ont une expression bizarre et bientôt le
ton va devenir celui du club animaux et
va devenir impératif
heureusement ça n'ira pas plus loin
aujourd'hui mais nous avons eu chaud
bien
enchaîner maintenant si vous le voulez
l'observation du pilier tus pose
d'emblée une grande question pourquoi
s'abreuvent style de façon ininterrompue
et bien une des raisons principales à
cela c'est empêcher les autres de boire
vieille coutume déjà utilisé au
moyen-âge tudieu
est trop coûteux l'emploi dans un coin
et ce soit en durabilité cette
histoire le dernier on
ce principe c'est bien sûr adapté au
cours des siècles ainsi entendait tout
en 1870 à cauet pour le chien robot puis
en 1914 raclée machenaud
en 1950 encore agréé viendra en 1960
après un cliché ne remporte actuellement
en l'absence de tout conflit armé le
pilier tous bistrot homme utilise une
formule valable à toute époque
l'adversaire
le pilier tu s'agit toujours pour une
grande cause nationale
cette cause peut-être économique
et
fonce vers la halle aux
veaux faire marcher un petit corps ouais
travaux s à cette cause peut être social
et c'est pour la sécu
alors ça ne nous regarde chez les curés
pas grand et
si les piliers tous forment une grande
famille ne sont pas se portent toujours
identique nous avons des exemples
différentes par exemple ceux beaucoup
plus de piliers du sac taurus classique
comme
il est déjà tombé
tout vu on a tout vu
oui
tout ce très beau film refuse débit
l'homme
la question reste celle ci n'a guère
dans l'âme et aux origines de l'homme
n'en aviez
soucieux de conserver toutes les
qualités de la race et on les comprend
les gouvernements ont toujours eu à
coeur de fournir au public et aux
piliers tus de belles formules incitatif
qui ont été tout de suite adopté
souvenez vous la première c'était
l'alcool tue lentement on s'en fout on
n'est pas pressé
l'un d'eux gratitude les filles et tous
utilisent largement ces nouvelles
formules en voici quelques exemples
courant sauter sa moyenne
ou encore et
raphaël va mourir
12h00 ou encore
gras et parents boivent les enfants
trinquent
nous ne remercierons jamais assez les
brillants publicitaires qui ont trouvé
ces formules généralement les libations
sont interrompus par des sonneries de
téléphone ce qui donne lieu à des
réactions de panique assez curieuse
regardez plutôt
oui eh les gars c'est pour vous c'est
bon femmes
les données avant de sortir du bistrot
mme lepic études vont en général se
plier à une dernière formalité au
japon allaient l'abroger
ça
c'est
quoi la tournée du patron aa
je suis je ne l'avais
pas vu ces photos réf ça ne serait pas
produit là à la mairie dernières
années avec parfois un événement imprévu
vient tout remettre en cause
allez encore un dixième a versé mardi
leur nom je te dis à verre ça va mais
trois verres bonjour les deux d'or
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]